ouais ce que je vous emmène aujourd'hui
je vous emmène hisser la garde et ça
c'est un grand immeuble derrière via la
scène on est devant chez dxomark avec
des équipes avec aurélie olivier kokou
et aujourd'hui on va venir combler de
leur protocole de test batterie on va
regarder comment ça je réalise que c'est
et ça c'est si c'est super intéressant
de parler protocole de test mettre ses
marmites comprend qu est ce qui est
intéressant dans la batterie du
smartphone il relate le soleil arrive
qu'est ce qu'on vient d'ôter quels sont
les points importants pour vous les
consommateurs et vous allez voir ce
sujet qui est extrêmement intéressant et
vous avez quasiment tout l'immeuble en
fait vous êtes partout je dis je vous ai
fait louper ascenseur si on veut
expliquer dit que ce mac en fait vous
tester les appareils vous testez les
batteries vous testé plein de choses
entrent chez xo marcon et des experts de
l'évaluation de la qualité des produits
d'électronique grand
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc tu aurélie c'est quoi ton job chez
dxomark car moi je suis une actrice pour
des coûts marketing chez lexmark
s'écoule directrice j'ai été directeur
d'orly bon alors vous faites quoi on
comprend donc vous testez vous à des
protocoles de test en fait non en fait
on a deux parties dxomark à une première
qui est concevoir de fabriquer et de
commercialiser des laboratoires de tests
dont celle voies équipées et fabricants
par exemple de smartphones pour pouvoir
aller améliorer la qualité de leurs
produits et après on a une deuxième
phase est qui est celle d'élaborer des
protocoles de test pour pouvoir évaluer
finement la qualité des smartphones par
exemple mais on n'évalue pas que des
smartphones chez dxomark donc est cool
aurélie comment est ce que vous l'avez
constituer notre protocole de test là on
est reparti de l'utilisateur en fait
aujourd'hui quand un utilisateur et un
minimum intéressés par la batterie et
qui veut s'acheter un nouveau smartphone
il a finalement très peu d'informations
à sa disposition pour pouvoir faire les
bons choix je sais qu'en fait une smart
phone il a une batterie j'ai pas de 5000
vidéos paire eur 6 millions terreur
ouais mais ça c'est un nombre c'est une
chaîne spécifications et au final
plusieurs produits avec la même capacité
de batterie ou pas du tout donner la
même autonomie donc toujours ce qu'on
souhaite via notre protocole de test
c'est d'avoir une dimension d'autonomie
une dimension aussi de temps de charge
pour pouvoir donner des bons éléments
aux consommateurs pour pouvoir faire les
bons choix et avoir un produit qui leur
corresponde m ok il a été là pour les
guider quoi on est là pour les guider
pour leur donner ces informations et
pour qu'il puisse se faire le bon choix
ok cool donc regardé plusieurs endroits
on va essayer de comprendre les
protocoles de tests voir comment ça
marche les oliviers est à côté de moi
vous avez travaillé ensemble avec henry
pour notre passé protocole de test
commence à fonctionner en fait comment
ça se fabrique un protocole vitesse
comme ça alors moi je suis l'ingénieur
des services early tu as raconté c'est
la directrice directrice produits dia
crise car effectivement on a travaillé à
deux chez dixons marque c'est toujours
la même stratégie on commence par bien
comprendre les besoins de l'utilisateur
ses attentes ses problèmes ses députés
conservateurs donc c'est facile aussi je
consomme à tort de haut niveau au niveau
de la batterie tu sais ce que c'est
qu'avoir une batterie qui tombe mal
c'est ce que c'est qu'avoir une charge
qui n'avance pas tu sais ce que c'est
que d'avoir smartphones où tu dis mais
c'est pas possible ça va jamais tenir
tout ça tu connais oui alors tout ça je
connais maintenant mettre dans la peau
de les gens qui sont pas dans le métier
des gens qui doivent découvrir bas c'est
plus compliqué tron a remarqué par
exemple c'est très simple quand tu
t'intéresses à l'achat d'un téléphone et
que tu regardes anthony une tonne de
spec il ya des mégapixels pour les
caméras il ya des milleirs en paire eur
pour la batterie les watts assez
compliqué nous on essaie d'évaluer sein
de manière simple et de transcrire sa
revanche et que tout le monde comprend
et ça c'est beau donc en fait ici on a
combien essentielle là on a un aussi ne
soit pas cotées ou non comme un espace
pourra venir regarder pour essayer de
comprendre au protocole de test alors
mais protocole de test j'ai trois
espaces dans lesquels je mesure
l'expérience utilisateur ici c'est une
un petit labo où il ya juste
l'oscilloscope je vais regarder tout ce
qui a trait à la charge on va aller tout
de suite dans un labo un peu plus
impressionnant qui s'appelle une cage de
faraday way dans laquelle je fais des
tests d'autonomie mais les tests
d'autonomie que j'ai fait dans ma cage
de faire un tel mobile bouge pas donc je
complète ces tests avec des tests en
mobilité à l'extérieur qui est trois
dans la rue en labo voilà un mal comme
la bosnie est donc aux mobilités ben je
teste les usages de tout le monde en
mobilité on passe des appels ont fait de
la navigation gps on prend des photos
des vidéos et puis on continue d'être
accro à ces réseaux sociaux auxquels
viendront trois autres le premier point
test qui a composé notre analyse de
l'autonomie ça va être le plan qu'on
appelle les scénarios d'usagé type donc
ça ça se passe dans une cage de faraday
ses colonnes que j'ai forgé pour
rappeler une cage de faraday en fait
c'est une cage qui va être constituée de
métal qui va complètement nous isoler en
fait des réseaux extérieurs d'accord qui
a rien qui passent là dedans tous car
l'intérieur et complètement aux pâquis
et ce comic packs l'extérieur ça
communique pas avec l'extérieur la seule
chose qu'on va faire ici pour bien
contrôler les conditions en fait c'est
qu'on a un réseau qui va être diffusé
dans la cage et c'est uniquement ce
réseau qui va être diffusé dans la cage
à thons propre réseau mobile en fait
voilà très classe c'est la classe faut
le dire ok j ai pris assez
impressionnant comme pourtant proposé
une tonne ton truc auquel on doit de
lumière ok donc là ses héros donc là on
est dans la cage de faraday donc ici on
va retrouver le diffuseur de réseau dans
la cage et on va retrouver no bot en
fait nos robots essentiellement ici ils
vont effectuer un scénario d'usagé type
donc c'est à dire qu'ils vont reproduire
en fait un scénario d'usagé pendant
quatre heures par jour donc ici c'est la
cage de faraday si on regarde bien la ja
olivier la ja or elle se cache là il ya
un robot du robot il y en a quatre c'est
un deux trois quartiers ici en fait avec
les robots olivier tu m'écris à 12 h par
un câble qui explique les tests comment
ça se passe ici en fait alors ce qu'on a
essayé de reproduire ici c'est un
scénario dû acheter un scénario usage
tips et les usages moyen constaté à
travers le monde les utilisateurs de
smartphones nokia en moyenne un
utilisateur va avoir son téléphone
allumé quatre heures par jour alors
certains vont bien sûr utiliser les
smartphones davantage d'autres - c'est
un usage moyen constaté c'est un
scénario qui va re trop dire une journée
type et tu vois ici on a des lumières ça
va reproduire les conditions lumineuses
et tu vas rencontrer au cours de la
journée avec une intensité un peu douces
le matin et le soir et au contraire
autour de l'heure du déjeuner une
musique très violente les mobiles sont
testés en mode cuisine par défaut et
donc ils vont devoir adapter la
luminosité de l'écran à ces conditions
lumineuses que tu vas rentrer dans la
journée ici leur présence de dieu temps
robot il simule tournoi offre exactement
c'est on a choisi la solution du robot
parce le robot peut utiliser le
téléphone comme toi et moi ce n'est pas
une suite logicielle qui va faire des
tests c'est un vrai doigts qui fait des
clips qui fait des swype donc ici tu le
vois en train de regarder les news voilà
il ya un scénario qui commence à 7h du
matin pour qu'il ya des activités de
shacknews mes mails ensuite peu plus
loin dans la journée je fais autre chose
jusqu'à en soirée j'ai beaucoup plus de
temps je fais énormément de je regarde
des vidéos je fais plein de plein de
choses qui se passent une nuit et le
lendemain matin la même routine
recommence exactement tant que le
smartphone bien sûr donc encore et
encore de la batterie ok évidemment
alors tu peux regarder un truc pour les
réveiller dans un petit bouton poussoir
parce que il faut quand même réveillé
sur tapant sur le bouton et puis tu as
l'impression qu'il est branché en fait
il est branché à une prise qui s'est
éteinte au moment du début de la
campagne ok voilà ok ça marche donc la
fête tu gères l'alimentation sur ta
prise ici en fait la totalité du labo
est pilotée en fait et donc les prises
sont déconnectés à distance dans un
scénario qui est absolument robuste et
qui nous permet de tester des exactement
de la même manière un téléphone android
un téléphone harmonie os téléphone à ios
sont peut aussi mesurer exactement de la
même manière un téléphone apple corps
pour qui si tu viens faire le têt dont
ton robot il réplique ta journée il fait
ajourner et continue avec différentes
conditions de luminosité avec un réseau
est complètement autonome jusqu'à ce que
mort s'ensuive c'est ça exactement et à
la fin de ce test qui peut durer deux
jours trois jours certains mobiles vont
même attaqué une quatrième journée à la
fin de ce test j'ai en fait pour une
charge complète l'autonomie que tu peux
espérer dans un visage type alors les
smartphones ils sont posés sur un robot
forcément c'est pas exactement les âges
qu'on en a bush aussi et donc c'est pour
ça que je complète avec des tests en
mobilité où je vais me concentrer sur la
mesure d autonomie qui peut espérer dans
les cas lisa jean mobilité la prise de
photo vidéo la navigation gps etc ça ce
sont mes deux premiers plans de tests
qui vont aller mesuré une autonomie type
allait mesurer l'autonomie par usage en
mobilité j'ai ensuite un autre plante
est où je reviens dans la cage remet les
smartphones sur les robots et cette fois
ci je l'allais calibre et donc ne plus
être dans les usines par défaut je vais
les calibrer la luminosité le niveau
audio et je vais à l'effigié tout le
monde 1 60 hertz pour les téléphones
qu'il veut peuvent aller jusqu'à plus
que sans alerte gelé figé tout sur des
conditions qui sont similaires et je
vais les évaluer sur un pied d'égalité
dans à peu près la totalité les usages
possibles d'un smartphone ça peut être
le streaming audio le streaming vidéo en
wifi ni reste tout cas engagé même le
playback je teste tous les usages
possibles avec son smartphone pour ici
aussi estimé l'autonomie qu'on peut
espérer pour chacun sait qu'à dix heures
tu me dis arrivent avec des autonomies
jusqu'à quatre jours j'ai jamais vu un
smartphone qui durica cech il ya deux
jours avec des smartphones des fois
moins mais que tu vas jamais laquelle
vous n'avez qu'à quelques endroits qui
se passera si si c'est possible tu dois
utiliser le téléphone plus que quatre
heures par jour toi je serai c'est parce
qu ils étaient 180 jours c'est ça
exactement et oui forcément moi j'ai un
visage différent de toi ma fille je vais
t'en parle pas mais qu'il utilise quatre
heures par jour c'est à dire comment
comptes-tu favorite au col de test comme
ça qui fait un protocole de test pour
imaginer un usage moyen pour monsieur
madame tout le monde est ce que monsieur
rien tout le monde l'utilisé sont que 24
heures par jour et bien écoute c'est la
moyenne dans le monde dont on voit par
clermont comme j'ai mesuré de manière
fine et précise la totalité des
autonomies durera que l'espérer avec un
smartphone je suis aussi capable de
reconstruire des profils différents là
par exemple sur les revues un smartphone
d'ex marc tu peux aller voir les
autonomies muselé j'ai quelqu'un qui par
exemple travaillent sur ordinateur toute
la journée sans toucher son téléphone et
donc nous a gelé gtx marx et 2h30
d'usagé jour le zazou modéré on l'a dit
c'est constater dans le monde par des
études ces quatre heures et il ya des
usages intense c'est jusqu'à 7 heures
d'usagé quand on donne ces autonomies
voilà on espère qu'on usage intense tu
passes au moins la journée c'est pas le
cas de tous les diverses certains
mobiles en usage intense à ce jour bien
qu'on ait des mauvais on frontaux disent
beaucoup de se battre et bien rapport à
une moyenne mondiale qui est 4 heures un
jour on ira beaucoup plus vite et bien
je ne pense pas je le crois qu'en france
on est exactement dans la moyenne des
pays où la moyenne est bien plus élevé
principalement des pays comme l'inde ou
l'amérique latine c'est souvent parce
que dans ces pays d'un moins
d'ordinateurs et donc l'accès internet
est quasiment exclusivement sur les
smartphones ok et donc les usages monte
jusqu'à 7 heures c'est pour ça que le
profil intense il à 7 heures au quai du
groupe
[Musique]
ok donc je vous ai expliqué donc le
scénario vous achetez complété par des
mobilités et puis ensuite encore des
tests en calibre et dans la cage de
faraday j'ai bien sûr un oscilloscope
pour qualifier la charge et ça ce sont
mes quatre plantes est au total au
nombre d'heures de test de charge de
décharge ça peut monter jusqu'à 150
heures pour les mobiles les plus
performants alors les plus performants
en autonomie les moins performants en
temps de charge je peux avoir jusqu'à
150 heures de tests hardy vice que je
mesure par mobile que je me voilà ses
quatre plans de tests vont ensuite me
constituer un score global est sain je
vais aller dans les détails avec toi et
donc ici là tu vas venir tester tout ce
qui va être chargé câble grâce à tourner
oscilloscopes c'est exactement ça donc
j'ai eu mon chargeur je vais mesurer
l'expérience de l'utilisateur donc je
vais mesurer le chargeur qui est fourni
dans la boîte si les pas fourni dans la
boîte je vais aller sur le site du
fabricant acheter le chargeur qui est
recommandé pour pouvoir essayer de
mesurer la meilleure expérience possible
entre le chargeur est le smartphone donc
là je vais bien sûr mesurer une charge
complète d'une batterie complètement
éteinte jusqu'à 100% je vais aussi aller
mesurer différents états de la batterie
à 20% à 40% et 60% je vais essayer de
voir en cinq minutes combien d'autonomie
tu récupères j'ai testé également la
charge sans fil ok parce qu'elle est
moins rapide elle est moins efficace
mais elle est bien pratique quand même
et ça tu le fais ici on fait pour voir
ça tu branches c'est brochet la
l'oscilloscope il récupère le solaire
électrique et lui il va te dire ça ça en
fait oui alors si tu regardes bien ça ça
vient du mur ici j'ai une prise un peu
bizarre en fait cette prise c'est une
sonde qui va mesurer la tension est là
tu vois j'ai une pince qui est sûre la
phase qui va aller mesurer le courant et
donc sombre de tensions sont de courant
je multiplie j'ai la consommation d'une
charge mesuré dans la prise du meilleur
je peux également aussi à les brancher
des instruments entre le boîtier est le
smartphone donc là on est cette fois ci
dans du courant continu sais pas si tu
te souviens de thé notions d'électricité
mais j'ai vachement il ya trente ans
avant le bloc charger on est sur le
courant alternatif délivré par ton
distributeur d'électricité après le bloc
largeur on est encore en continu de ce
courant continu je peux également le
durée ce qui me permet de connaître
l'efficacité du boîtier d'accord il ne
retransmet par toute l'énergie qu'il
consomme pas ce qu'ils chauffent aussi
un petit peu et ça ça veut dire une
déperdition d'énergie et tout ça on vous
en parle on les suit dans une vidéo on
vous parle effectivement de la charge
tout ce qu'il faut savoir les bonnes
pratiques les chargeurs ce qu'il faut
utiliser le gros chargeurs quel chargeur
et c'est ça le lien est dans la
description allez voir vous allez voir
c'est super intéressant donc soit on
robots et sert à quoi en fait celui là
il sert à calibrer iliad est en fait à
découvrir un smartphone et l calibré
pour le test c'est ça c'est à dire que
le robot par défaut il connait pas ton
téléphone là ici sa caméra de computer
vie jeunes qui lui permet de reconnaître
les icônes mais on lui a pas appris la
totalité des interfaces utilisateurs qui
peuvent exister entre un apple ou un
samsung au pot ou ainsi remis le design
de l'icône qui permet de lancer un appel
peu changé et c'est ici qu'on va
apprendre robots aux robots à utiliser
un smartphone c'est ici qu'on va lui
apprendre à rentrer à débloquer l'écran
a sélectionné la totalité des icônes
dont on a besoin pour nos tests revenir
en arrière avec des swype avec des
tables ça dépend de l'interface
utilisateur qui est implémenté sur le
smartphone est donc c'est ici qu'ils
découvrent les nouveaux téléphones alors
si c'est le petit frère d'un mobile
qu'on a déjà testé ça peut aller très
très vite parce qu'en fait j'avais un
marché pareil il va tout reconnaître ça
peut prendre 20 30 minutes si c'est un
modèle qui est tout nouveau ça peut nous
prendre jusqu'à une demi journée d'aller
configurer et d'apprendre un nouveau
téléphone fait ou si ici qu'on va aller
est ce que vous pensez qu'on écoute
est ce que vous pensez qu'on souhaitait
j'en ai peur j'en ai peur c'est aussi
sur ce robot qu'on appelle le robot de
baisse et là dessus aussi qu'on va aller
développer les nouveaux quatre tests
qu'on va développer les nouvelles
fincher qui basculeront en test dans une
mise à jour prochaine du protocole de
test des smartphones ok alors que je
comprenne bien vous allez mesurer ce
qu'on appellera l'autonomie c'est un
premier pas ces singes est à peu près en
parenthèse qui vont des centaines de
l'est j'ai compté trente mesures c'est
beaucoup ensuite on mesure charge
l'impression d'être prof à la fac on est
d'accord c'est 5 et là le troisième est
là tu me perds un peu c'est ce qu'on va
appeler l'efficacité et l'efficacité
voilà ça c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué à comprendre autant
l'autonomie on arrive bien à voir
l'efficacité ma mesure sur deux critères
l'efficacité d'une charge et
l'efficacité en usage or l'efficacité
d'une charge la batterie elle a une
capacité d'énergie mais ton vin water et
l'efficacité de la charge sait combien
je dois tirer dans la prise pour remplir
ces 20 watts heure 6 et 25 chiché encore
compter 20 watts heure / 25 watts heure
ça me fait une efficacité de 80% trop de
matchs à st didier en fait si je
comprends si j'ai un smartphone et une
batterie de 5 millions perreux gens mais
deux en france inquiète basket avec mira
quien offrir 5000 oui ils ont tous les
deux la même pris deux boîtes rien qui
ne changera pas le cap à charge rapide
au niveau du score à battre est celui
qui est la mienne base à trith 5015 à
charge rapide il aura un meilleur score
mais si j'en deviens qu'à une plus
petite batterie c'est la même chose
rapide alors ça c'est l'efficacité en
usage en usant ouais alors l'efficacité
un usage qu'est ce qu'on mesure c'est ça
exactement ça c'est à dire qu avec qui
j'ai une autonomie de deux jours c'est
bien avant avec 5000 c'est bien je suis
content d'avoir deux jours d'autonomie
si un mobile avec 3500 milliampères il y
passe cinq mille et à 3500 il propose
également deux jours d'autonomie c'est
plus fort encore c'est plus fort parce
que avec probablement un design un peu
plus font probablement un peu plus léger
il arrive quand même à proposer la même
expérience autonomie et donc c'est un
mobile efficace efficace en usage
différent de l'efficacité pendant la
charge choqué donc on voit qu'un haut
taux de oui il ya la charge et ya
l'efficacité qui sont les trois critères
comment est-ce que tu les différents
sites parce que là tu vois on dit là
j'ai quand même trois points essentiels
vous invite à me relire je sais que
j'écris donc au tour de me charger
efficacité c'est quand même plus
important dans le sport alors ça reste
l'autonomie des l'autonomie il a un
poids de 3 ok voilà c'est ça exactement
c'est plus important parce que de toute
façon il ya encore beaucoup de gens qui
charge le téléphone pendant la nuit donc
pour le taux de charge plein bien c'est
pas terrible donc s'arrête l'autonomie
hockey le plus important la charge avec
toutes les charges rapide qui arrive
finalement les habitudes changent et
puis quel que soit son rituel de charge
il ya un moment où on va être à court de
batterie et on va être content de
pouvoir compter sur une bonne autonomie
plus la charge elle a un poids de 2 2 2
notez vous aussi alors efficacité bon
efficacité c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
expérience c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
vit est ce que ça consomme beaucoup de
remplir ma batterie est ce que il a
besoin d'avoir grosse batterie pour
proposer une bonne autonomie on le sent
pas trop mais quand même yann un poids
de 1 hockey et pourquoi c'est important
pour dxomark pour trois raisons la
première raison c'est comme on le disait
tout à l'heure avec une petite batterie
si tu arrives à proposer une meilleure
autonomie une bonne autonomie le bonus
immédiat pour l'utilisateur c'est qu'il
a un téléphone plus fin il a un
téléphone plus léger et voilà c'est un
truc visible quand même le deuxième
argument est le deuxième raison pour
laquelle c'est important pour nous mais
jusqu'à 6 tc caen fait un mobile qui est
efficace il a probablement des bons
composants il a probablement une
intégration hardware qui a été bien fait
bien penser il a probablement un
software qui a été bien optimisé donc en
fait ce score d'efficacité c'est un pont
un score de la vanité qui a été mise
dans la fabrication de ce téléphone le
dernier règle arguments bien si tu
consommes moins six tueurs plus
longtemps en fait c'est un peu un mobile
qui est sympa pour la planète c'est le
côté écolo donc c'est aussi important
pour nous en quelques mois les ondes du
smartphone efficace alors les plus
efficaces sont les smartphones où il ya
le moins d'efforts à faire de la part du
fabricant l'intégration sont les deux
iphone que j'ai mesuré en quelles sont
les deux mobiles les plus efficaces
alors je dis que c'est il ya le moins
d'effort côté apple ça reste des efforts
mais ils ont développé eux mêmes le
chipset ils ont développé eux-mêmes le s
ils ont développé eux mêmes la plupart
des applications qui sont embarqués
section qui s'est forcément sur optimisé
l'iphone 12 min il tient deux jours en
usage modéré et il a une batterie de
2000 227 millions terreur on n'avait pas
vu ça depuis hier d'années dans le monde
android à ses dires c'est dire ok c'est
hyper efficace et cela ça veut dire que
lui un super score il ya une bonne
autonomie c'est ça la charge du correct
c'est ça mais ils y pratiquent en ce
sens exact eh bien il est dans notre top
score c'est l'iphone 12 pro mac ce qui
était quatrième au lancement de notes le
protocole qui était le quatrième alors
le numéro un aujourd'hui on tourne je
lutte au titre dès le 1er juillet 2021
si vous arrivez du futur il faut nous re
situer un petit peu d'accord donc ça
c'est qui le dr aujourd'hui alors
aujourd'hui le top score c'est un mobile
samsung le m51 ok c'est un mobile qui a
été construit avec une batterie de
mammouth qui propose une autonomie
incroyable
il a une charge qui est très efficace et
hylas 1 efficacité globale qui est un
mobile bien fait ok il est bon sur tous
les critères et ça lui permet d'être
notre top score trop cool ok je crois
qu'on a tout dit sur la réalisation de
magna de protocole bien sûr on a un
score global qui résume tout ce monde là
notre totale de la totale et tout ça
mais on est aussi capable de proposer
des informations très claires aux
clients parce que on a un score ça
permet de comparer les diverses mais on
a aussi dans les revues fallait voir sur
le site dicks marcoing comme on
retranscrit aussi les autonomies qu'on
peut espérer avec le smartphone en
fonction de son usage est modérée ou
intense on va savoir directement quelle
est l'autonomie qu'on peut espérer avec
chacun des modèles que nous avons testés
et on a aussi les tantes charges qui
sont tout simple mais qui nous permet de
savoir combien de temps je peux
récupérer 80% de maths charge combien de
temps pour finir de charger le téléphone
en entier et combien je récupère au bout
de 30 minutes ok voilà ça ça me va
simplement on va pas danger phase 1
j'écris mal il s'est pas laissé sa vie
sinon ça va on connaît bien merci a vous
de me regarder cette vidéo voilà comme
ça vous savez comment des lic sonar qui
fabrique ces protocoles de tête vous
avez compris ça c'est plutôt intéressant
merci de m'avoir accueillie chez vous
mais merci à toi rien c'était très
agréable bien merci c'est aussi très
agréable vous de me dire vous ce que
vous en pensez pas ce qui est toujours
intéressant d'avoir votre tout est en
fait moi je vous invite à dire découvre
un protocole de test par pascal et porto
connotation son fichier nommé comprendre
la note globale la note finale qu'est ce
qu'ils jouent derrière tout ça qu'est ce
qui se passe et comment et c'est ça qui
est vachement intéressant réussir à
sortir ces trois éléments tonomy la
charge l'efficacité maintenant dites moi
vous votre smartphone embarquant
commentaires celle qu'elle est ce que
vous pensez qu'il est bon on change est
ce que vous pensez qu'il a une bonne
autonomie est ce que vous pensez qu'il
est efficace voulu marquer en maintenant
vous allez voir sur le cd dxomark devant
le résultat vous verrez si vous êtes
dans le vrai ou pas du tout à un sursaut
des bisous des bisous masques et à
bientôt pour la seconde boucle
[Musique]